they suffer from their post-colonial
masters orders these orders are
basically
that we give you morality we will tell
you what is right or wrong so where
they're coming from is this we're living
the 21st century
the norms of today have changed things
we look at differently homes of today
are the following here's the criteria
and here's the yardstick that's going to
change probably a hundred years later
assalamu alaikum whereas your brothers
and sisters and dear friends welcome to
this video
now the reason i titled this video um
new muslim these ex-muslim it's not that
we have a little conflict or you know
you know we have you know some kind of a
beef going on yeah just to grab your
attention a bit you know
we do have our disagreements with the
ex-muslim community those who are
really ex-muslim by the way uh because
we do have a lot of uh
faiths coming out a lot with
emotional reasons of leaving and blaming
islam
now i was thinking to myself lately
and there's been some videos that have
been made by some ex-muslims
females and males as well now the
question that we need to
really ask is this what is the
difference between
new muslims and muslims who are born
muslims
and the ex-muslims what is the
difference now me i came to islam in
2012 23rd of december
yeah now i'm still a muslim
but the people right underneath me as
you can see
yeah over here these these individuals
they are excellent muslims some of them
are fake
some of them have left it for emotional
reasons now the question that i really
want to ask is the following
what is the difference between us and
them besides them leaving the photo of
islam
yeah maybe with ignorance or for
emotional reasons
and people like myself now
i know what they know maybe we look at
the world in a different way but
we know for example i know the prophet
peace be upon his marriage to aisha
i know the prophet saws married to
safiyyah
and her we know the prophet saws was
we know the prophet sallam did certain
things
we know allah has legislated certain
things in the quran
yeah be it the the polygamy
be it um not taking jews and christians
as your friends but which kind of jews
and christians are friends just to put
in context here
all of these things i'm aware of these
so what has caused these people to say
hey
we don't want nothing else to do we
don't want enough to do with this
religion
and then people like myself seeing well
we want
a lot to do with our religion you know
we're actually proud of our religion and
you know we are happy with our lord we
are proud of our prophet salallahu
you know and we love our we love islam
we love our religion
what is the difference what is it that
makes us stay in islam
and makes these individuals which you
can see on the screen
say no we don't want to do nothing we
don't want anything to do with it
now i came to a conclusion after
thinking you know
why this is the difference
and i don't mean to cause offence but
it's just to highlight the issue
yeah i believe these
so-called ex-muslims yeah some of them
some of them are genuine some of them
are not yeah but very little are genuine
they have in my eyes what they've done
is this
they have an inferiority complex so
therefore they have they suffer from
their post-colonial masters orders
these orders are basically that we give
you morality
you know we will tell you what is right
or wrong so where they're coming from is
this we're living the 21st century
the norms of today have changed things
we look at differently
think this how we think it happens and
this how it happens so the
subjective norms of today are the
following here's the criteria
and here's the yardstick that's going to
change probably 100 years later
and this is what we're going by and this
is the reason why
now we are feeling inferior having
inferiority complex
so therefore you know our post-colonial
masters have told us that look this is
how it needs to be
so we look at islam and go oh looking
with these glasses wait let's put these
glasses on
okay okay that looks bad
guys can you see that that looks bad
whoa whoa the prophet did that
that looks that looks wrong that looks
bad
the quran that that is like you can we
cannot tolerate this
this is exactly what's happened so when
they give the glasses to
us new muslims or muslims who are born
muslims because they
heard about the prophet we got to know
the prophet
it wasn't he say oh he said that and
then oh
no it's they heard about it we got to
know him
properly you know when you get to know
someone you need to know them probably
before you
judge them so we said okay let's look at
these
uh with these glasses that you're
looking at okay let's look
hmm okay so
we understand why you see the matter
like that
we understand why you want to leave
islam because you have a yardstick and
goggles that are clouded you know with
all these philosophical
ideas you know these with these
fallacious
double standards so that's why when you
look at islam and the quran
that's why it looks very abnormal to you
new muslims like myself
we take those goggles and we clean them
and we say look let's let's look at the
real picture let's get all those little
dirty things out the way
and those lies and misconceptions and
miscontext
statements of miscontext misconstrued
um statements and then we look at it
clearly
that is the difference between us new
muslims
and those who are born muslims and the
ex-muslims
that is our difference they chose to
obey their post colonial masters to tell
them what is why it's
right and wrong and they said okay sir
yep sir and they looked at islam and
said oh that looks terrible
that doesn't look right and that is the
reason why they have decided to go that
way
and we have decided to stand strong and
firmly
that is the difference now i want to ask
another question i know some of them are
a lot of them actually i think all of
them are going to watch this
firstly i ask allah to guide you guys
back ask allah to guide you guys back
now the question that needs to be asked
is this i want to speak to the
ex-muslims now
some of them have done videos where
they've gone over like oh the prophet
did this and your prophet did that and
the prophet and then it's just like one
after another it's like like okay all
right no problem no problem
argumentation no problem
if i came to you guys and said you know
what your mum your mum and your dad
your mum and dad are thieves
your mum and dad did this your mum and
dad went and did that
your mom and dad went and did this and
that and that
you're gonna automatically go in the
defensive mode and be like well hold on
a second hold on a second
don't talk about my mom and dad like
that there is context
for everything that you've said about
them i can explain to you
why they did this and that there's a
context because at that time
or this time this happened and it's
because of this i know my mom and dad i
know they wouldn't do that
for that reason how lovely
how amazing you have the right you have
the right to defend
their honor and say no we need to know
that in that why this happened
and rightly so so when you come and
accuse the prophet sallallahu alaihi
of certain things we do not fall into
or not you guys or anyone comes and says
this whoever it is non-muslims
in general comma says this we don't just
go okay you know what
all right i see no we say we know our
prophet sallallahu alaihi
we know what he went through we know how
merciful he is
we know when he says something he there
is a reason behind it we know when he
did something there's a reason why he
did it
that is the difference between us and
you
and that difference will always be there
always will be there
because it's a state of mind it's the
way you look at things
just because some of them have apostates
why because
things are getting a little hard oh it's
hard to practice
that's your reason that's your reason
that because you cannot handle surfings
and certain things have become hard
that's the reason you've decided to
leave islam it's pathetic
you're leaving the father of islam not
because of his fundamental frauds
in his principles or his doctrine you're
leaving this time because
emotionally because emotional reasons it
doesn't sound right to me
it's hard i don't want to practice it
and the funniest thing is
most of these ex-muslims become atheists
and then
they try to question the morality of in
islam
as an atheist you have no basis
morality is so subjective it doesn't
make sense
and some of them have genuinely gone
through emotional things
they have suffered things in life and i
understand i relate look
we all go three things we all get tested
and i ask allah that
the trousers put you through to help you
cut overcome them but that's still not
an excuse or a valid excuse to leave the
father of islam if tomorrow
i said i'm leaving islam because this
happened in my life and that
emotionally okay i might be upset but
that has
no reason that's got nothing to do with
islam
oh my lord nothing it's my shortcoming
it's my shortcoming you know i could be
stronger
yes i could go for that little moment
but i could overcome it also
so that's the reason why that is the
difference
between us new muslims reverse the islam
born muslims and yourselves and that
difference will always be there so
instead of me
replying to all of you guys as you can
see on the screen
no we've got a little treat for you
we have a new show coming called the y
files and
in this video on this show we will be
debunking
every single one of misconceptions and
lies and accusations and
all these kind of um things that are
thrown
towards islam every single one of them
will be debunked
and answered one by one
and then we hope that by us answering
these you can understand
and take off those goggles and this
inferiority complex
and say to your postcolonial masters you
will not
tell me what is right or wrong
yeah i will listen to my lord
because he's the one who's created me
and he is the one who is more deserving
of telling me
what is right and what is wrong so in a
nutshell guys
this was just my message because instead
of addressing and some of them are
attention seekers so i'm not going to
entertain them if you have minimum 100
000 subscribers
we can talk we can have a debate a
discussion here why not
but for those who are using my name to
climb up the ladder
first you need to get a ladder so in a
nutshell
genuinely it was a video just to show
you guys the difference
because it's really important for us to
understand this you know
they act like they have just made this
discovery like we are the clever ones
and we know and we found this out and we
left
no we know exactly what you know we
hear exactly what you hear you chose to
be
the weak ones you chose to be the ones
that follow the
you know uh like a sheep just follow
you know the herd you know jump off the
cliff and you just jump off with them
let's end with a verse from the quran
because allah talks about these matters
let's end with a quran recitation from
prophet muhammad hijab
mashallah with this beautiful voice may
allah preserve him and let's end with
that note
and inshallah that will be a reminder to
our dear ex-muslim
genuine ones friends and those who claim
to be an ex-muslim
and inshallah you can understand the
difference between us and yourself and
we ask allah to guide you and guide
ourselves
islam is perfect the prophet sallallahu
alaihi is perfect
our lord is perfect and inshallah
you will come back and if not to you
your way
to me my way like allah says in the
quran says
disbelievers i will not worship what you
worship
you will not worship what i worship
neither am i going to worship what you
worship
and neither will you worship what i
worship to you your religion
and to me mine
my